Це шахтарське місто Червоноград на Львівщині.
Тут першими в СРСР скинули пам'ятник Леніну - ще в 1990 році.
В одному з храмів міста горять у пеклі Путін і радянський прапор.
А от назва міста поки лишається незмінною.
Назва "Червоноград" містить російську імперську символіку.
Такого висновку у серпні 2023 року дійшов інститут нацпам'яті.
Відтоді у Червонограда було півроку, аби визначитися з новою назвою.
Але згоди з цього приводу в місті досі немає.
Відбулися громадські обговорення й електронне голосування. Найбільше містян хочуть, аби Червоноград перейменували на…
Червоноград! Так і є гарно - Червоноград.
- Як має називатися місто? - Я за Червоноград.
Так, як є - так і має називатись.
Мені подобається назва Червоноград.
Та керівниця місцевого музею і дослідниця історії міста Галина Гриник розповідає:
історична назва Червонограда - Кристинопіль.
1692 рік. Ми від цього року вели літочислення міста Кристинополя.
Назва міста пов'язана з іменем дружини засновника нашого міста Фелікса Казимира Потоцького.
Фелікс Казимир Потоцький одружився із Кристиною із роду Любомирських.
Ці землі довго належали Польщі.
А у 1951-му відійшли до Радянського Союзу.
Тоді ж у регіоні почали будувати вугільні шахти.
Довкола них виросло нове місто - Червоноград.
Галина Гриник дослідила публікації в місцевій пресі радянського часу, де пояснюється, як обирали назву "молодому місту".
Тут гарно написано: "Коли 36 років тому, коли йшлося про нову назву,
новому місту над Західним Бугом, особливих дискусій не виникало:
"червоне місто Червоноград, від кольору революції наша назва, від кольору її прапора".
Вадима, переселенця з Донеччини, назва "Червоноград" дивує,
адже нагадує про радянське минуле.
Коли приїхали, я запитував: ну, це ж комуністична назва Червоноград.
Ні, ні, ви що, це наша, українська. Я ж поліз у Вікіпедію. До 51-го року, це було Кристинопіль.
А потім, коли обмін з поляками був, став Червоноград.
Мені більше подобається Кристонопіль. Стара назва, вона дуже класна, дуже файна.
А от жителі Червонограда історію назви свого міста трактують по-різному.
Це дуже гарне місто, і воно з Червоноградом якось асоціюється, і назва така красива.
Не знаю… І що, перейменовувати все радянське?
- А що це комуністична назва, кажуть? - А яка різниця?
Аби робота була, гроші платили людям.
Ну, комуністична - може після війни давайте перейменуємо.
Якби це була комуністична, була б калина зелена, а не червона.
Воно, як було в червоних маках, так воно і останеться Червоноградом.
Всюди кругом тут червоні маки цвіли.
Частина жителів міста все ж підтримує стару назву - Кристинопіль.
Або Христинопіль - на український лад.
Колись така назва була - Христинопіль.
Я так думаю, що має бути така стара назва Христинопіль.
Якщо чесно сказати, то "червоне" мені вже отут сидить.
Христина - мені так більше подобається, Христина - Христинопіль.
А дехто вважає, що Кристинопіль - така ж колоніальна спадщина, що й Червоноград.
Ну, а при чому тут ми і Христинопіль? Тоді як, будемо називати на честь жінки графа Потоцького, який гнобив людей, Україну?
Місцева волонтерка й студентка Києво-Могилянської академії Анастасія Безпалько
не підтримує ані радянську, ані польську назви.
Зараз ми можемо дякувати полякам за всю їхню підтримку,
за всю їхню допомогу. Але просто варто таки опиратися на своє, на своє коріння, на щось українське,
для того, щоб вже потім точно не довелося знову перейменовуватися,
тому що з кимось якісь будуть відносини зіпсовані.
Тому дівчина запропонувала свій варіант - Шептицький -
на честь Андрея Шептицького, митрополита Української греко-католицької церкви,
громадського й церковного діяча.
Шептицький тут приймав, зокрема, вічні обіти.
І вічні обіти - це такий дуже символічний момент в житті будь-якого монаха.
І, власне, для Шептицького це так само був той момент, коли він переходив
із римо-католицької віри в греко-католицьку.
Я для себе знайшла символізм у тому, що Шептицький - це так само про вибір бути українцем.
Тобто коли ти пройшов дуже багато різних етапів,
коли різні імперії намагалися впливати на твій вибір і на твою ідентичність,
зокрема, але ти все одно намагаєшся докопатися до тієї правди в Україні і зрозуміти, хто ж ти є.
Волонтер і учасник АТО Юрій Карплюк теж проти польської назви,
а у слові "Червоноград" радянського сліду не вбачає.
На його думку, під час війни перейменування "не на часі".
А вже після її завершення, каже Юрій, можна було б назвати місто на честь когось із героїв-військових.
І якщо прийдуть ці герої сюди, живі, здорові, я сподіваюсь,
що їх максимальна кількість прийде і мінімально поляже,
то вони також мають приймати участь, чи треба перейменувати місто, чи не потрібно.
А зараз вони всі там. І їхнє слово для мене більш важливе, ніж Інституту національної пам'яті.
У міськраді кажуть: відповідно до закону про декомунізацію, місто все ж слід перейменувати до 27 січня 2024 року.
Тим не менш на електронне голосування крім десятка пропозицій нової назви винесли варіанти "Червоноград",
"Перейменування не на часі" і "Проти перейменування".
Заступник міського голови пояснює:
ці варіанти включили в голосування, щоб у місті не виникло соціальної напруги.
Для того, щоб була якась картинка об'єктивна,
для того, щоб не було якоїсь соціальної напруженості,
ми все-таки включили ті варіанти, щоб кожен міг висловити свою думку.
А ми - побачити реальну картину.
Завершилося тим, що ані місцеві жителі, ані депутати міськради
так і не змогли дійти згоди щодо нової назви й направити свою пропозицію до Верховної Ради.
Тож тепер як називатиметься Червоноград, вирішуватимуть у Києві.
Чому перейменування Червонограда виявилося таким складним?
Заступник міського голови каже: постійно спростовує побоювання,
що перейменування - це дорого.
Запевняє: людям не треба буде міняти документи, а гроші з бюджету витратять лише на зміну табличок на в'їзді
в місто й на кількох адмінбудівлях. Також чиновник пояснює, чому перейменування "на часі".
Я розумію, що треба все-таки загальнонаціональний інтерес
ставити трошки вище своїх особистих амбіцій і пріоритетів.
Якщо держава вже взяла курс, то треба тим курсом рухатися.
Тобто тут вже не мешканцям міста визначати на часі, чи не на часі.
Тут треба виконувати закон, який є написаний.
Громадський активіст Вадим Поздняков, який відстежує процеси декомунізації,
вважає, що спокійному перейменуванню нашкодила сама міська влада.
Адже не проводила серед населення роз'яснювальну роботу.
Те, що відбувається в Червонограді, активіст називає "зривом деколонізації".
Головна проблема в тому, що громада вже зі старту пішла на порушення,
коли вони включили назву Червоноград у список потенційно взагалі можливих.
А врешті-решт вони, та й не тільки Червоноград, а багато інших міст, зараз намагаються грати в те, що ось якісь там місцеві вибори будуть,
давайте зараз пограємо в те, що ми нібито намагалися зберегти назву, а нам нав'язав нову Київ.
Що по суті є дуже шкідливим наративом.
Керівниця музею Галина Гриник пояснює заплутане сьогодення складною історією.
У 1939 році тодішній польський Кристинопіль окупували німці.
Тоді ж виїхало майже все єврейське населення.
Коли закінчилася Друга світова й місто повернулося до Польщі, почалося виселення українців.
Виселяли людей у Тернопільську область. Отут, скажімо, в нас є така посвідка на евакуацію 1946 року.
Між іншим, це моя родина, я її сюди принесла, мою родину також виселяли,
вони тут недалеко жили. Це був надзвичайно страшний період,
тому що я, скажімо, на своїх родинних переживаннях, на своїх родинних документах,
я просто плачу, коли піднімаю ті всі документи.
А коли місто перейшло з Польщі до СРСР, з нього виїхали поляки.
Корінних жителів майже не лишилося.
Працювати в "молодому шахтарському місті" приїхали люди з різних куточків Радянського Союзу.
Вони поселилися й жили вже в місті з назвою Червоноград.
Багато людей, які і не хочуть знати тої історії.
Для них, знаєте, Червоноград став символом червоної калини, символом червоної рути.
Ну, і це є шкода, тому що хто не знає свого минулого, той, знаєте, не буде мати майбутнього.
Міський музей розташований у палаці графа Потоцького - засновника Кристинополя.
Це одна з небагатьох історичних будівель, які збереглися в місті.
Вона постраждала від двох світових воєн. За часів радянського Червонограда тут діяла вечірня школа.
Два роки тому запланований ремонт палацу довелося відкласти
- почалося повномасштабне вторгнення. Ця будівля бачила й увібрала в себе всю складну історію цих земель.
Її неможливо перекреслити, як би не змінювалися назви міста.